it's Michelle from Lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry nerd and owner of
pink hair I've always wanted unicorn
hair ever since the hair chalk craze of
2013 and so when all the Plexes came onto
the market and I could finally get this
sort of hair I was so excited but the
problem is I'm also really lazy so I
knew that if having this sort of pastel
hair would mean that I would have to
keep going to the hairdresser and doing
hair masks and all of that sort of stuff
I knew it just wasn't going to happen
so before I went off and bleached my
hair I did a lot of research to check if
I could actually keep it up because
bleaching hair is not cheap and I didn't
want to just throw my money away
I've had this bleached hair since July
so I've had it for about a year and a
half and so this is what works for me
this is the lazy girl's coloured hair care
routine if you like this sort of video
please click the like button subscribe
to my channel and click the notification
bell so you don't miss any videos also
leave me a comment telling me what else
you want me to talk about next so before
you go and get your hair bleached I
think it's really important to make sure
you're getting it bleached the right way
firstly you want to minimize damage
because damaged hair is going to require
so much more upkeep so make sure your
hairdresser is using some sort of
bonding agent like olaplex
to keep your hair in as good a condition
as possible hair is dead and so once
it's damaged it's really hard to do any
sort of repair to it you can modify it
to make it less damaged or feel less
damaged or act like it's less damaged
but you can't really reverse the damage
properly the other thing is the pattern
of bleaching you're getting done so if
you want a full head of bleached hair
the hairdresser will bleach it right up
to the roots or even on the scalp the
problem with this for a lazy person is
that when it grows out it will be like a
line and so once it gets to about there
you have to go back to the hairdresser
and redo the roots or redo it yourself I
knew that that was just not going to
happen with me and so I got my
hairdresser to bleach it in what's
called a balayage or a blended root that
means that the amount of each hair that
gets bleached is not quite the same so
it's lots of different lengths that
means that when it grows out it will
grow out as this sort of blended
gradient rather than a harsh line the
downside to this is that if you want to
get your hair rebleached if you want to
redo the growth it's really really
difficult for the hairdresser to do that
without rebleaching bits that are already
bleached and that will probably cause
your hair to snap off so my
hairdresser pretty much said see you in
two years so because that's what I
wanted that was great but keep in mind
that if you are lazy you might not get
exactly the look you want another thing
that I think is really important for a
lazy upkeep style is the choice of colour
hair likes to go brassy and Asian hair
especially likes to go brassy really
quickly this is when it starts to look
orange and this means that warm colors
are going to be a lot easier to keep
than cool colors I started with a really
cool purple which I loved but it
required me to shampoo my hair with
purple shampoo twice a week it would
actually start to grow brassy around Day
4 so even if I wasn't planning to
wash my hair I had to just spray it with
tons and tons of purple spray now that I
have a warmer color it actually works
really well what you do is you mix the
dye so that it's a little bit cooler
than what you actually watched and the
brassiness will actually add the warmth
for you and so it sort of blends in the
brassiness
it makes it look like it's intentional
another important thing to do is to pick
a colour that looks good as it fades out
in general pinks and purples look nice
greens and blues tend to look less nice
but it really depends on the specific
dye you're using so what I recommend is
looking up reviews and photos of what
the colour looks like as it fades so that
you can make sure that it's a colour
you're happy with so that if you do get
lazy you're not stuck with a nasty colour
you're not into if you're really
committed to a particular colour it might
be a good idea to pick a dye that stains
your hair so again you can look this up
in reviews the problem is if you then
want to change your hair color you might
have to do something that will damage
your hair at least a little bit you
might have to bleach it or do what I did
which was use Katie's direct dye fading
method which was gentler than bleach but
it still did cause a bit of damage you
can see me doing that method in a video
tutorial I'll link that in the
description another important thing to
think about is how bright your hair
colour is
generally the brighter it is the more
fuss it is so if you have bright hair it
tends to bleed dye everywhere it bleeds
it into towels it bleeds it onto
light-colored sofas and chairs that you
lean on when your hair is wet it might
also stain white clothes if you ever
want to go into a float tank then you'll
have to wait until your hair stops
bleeding otherwise you might have to pay
a massive cleanup fee and your shower
can get quite stained as well pastel
colors are usually a bit safer because
there's just less dye there to bleed out
they can also help you save a bit on
hair dye because if you're using
temporary colour you can just dilute it
with white hair conditioner which is
pretty cheap I also redye my hair
every time I wash my hair using a dye
conditioner and I think this is probably
the number one thing that saved me time
in this whole hair routine journey the
product I use for this is this hair dye
which dyes your hair in three minutes
it's a Korean brand called espesso plus
now my friend was doing bright pink hair
and he complained that this would stain
his shower so bad but since I'm doing
more pastel I just dilute this into hair
conditioner and I don't have this
problem as much before I was using a dye
conditioner I was just redyeing my
hair once every 2 or 3 weeks it would
take about 45 minutes to apply the dye
during this time I listened to a podcast
so it wasn't like I was completely
wasting my time and then I would sit
around for maybe four hours and then
rinse it out afterwards one of the
brands I really liked for this is brite
organix the nice thing about these
temporary hair dyes is that they don't
tend to damage your hair so you can
leave it on for as long as you like
they're just conditioners if you leave
it the longer it does tend to stain your
hair though if that's a problem for you
so now I use a dye conditioner I
dilute this into hair conditioner in a
lush tub and then I apply it onto my
hair like it's hair conditioner by the
time I've worked the conditioner through
my hair and untangled all my hair with
my fingers it's about three minutes and
so once I rinse it off I get the color I
want the downside of course is that
you're using a lot more dye because a
lot less if it gets into your hair a lot
more of it goes down the drain but I am
happy to sacrifice that small amount of
money for the massive convenience it is
I also use a purple shampoo about once a
fortnight even though my hair is this
warm color it does sometimes get a
little bit too warm and
orange and so this tones it down a bit
my favorite purple shampoo so far is
this one the fudge professional clean
blonde violet toning shampoo I really
like it because a lot of purple shampoos
tend to be really drying and so it
leaves your hair feeling like straw and
it's really difficult to untangle this
one does not which is great it's still
really really pigmented though so you do
still get a lot of cooling with very
little effort if you've read my blog
you'll know that I am a massive fan of
amodimethicone this has been such a game
changer ingredient for my hair it is
probably the number one thing that my
hair can't live without now before I
bleached my hair it wasn't that impressive
but now that I have it is so different
from all the other silicones there are
two things that make amodimethicone
really really cool firstly it has a
positive charge what this means is that
it will bind to more damaged regions of
your hair which tend to have a more
negative charge secondly it means that
it doesn't form a really thick film that
weighs down your hair once you have
enough amodimethicone on your hair
the positive charge is quite positive
and so anymore amodimethicone will be
repelled because like charges repel I
didn't really have a problem with
dimethicone before I bleached my hair
but after I bleached my hair I found
that it tends to weigh my hair down
quite a lot secondly amodimethicone
forms a film that lasts through several
washes if you're trying to treat your
hair with a treatment like olaplex then
maybe this isn't so good but I found
that it really does protect your hair in
between you doing things to it and so
you still get that detangling you still
get the lack of snags which is really
important because that's what causes
permanent damage that can't be reversed
I had a few products that I really liked
that contain amodimethicone but as my
luck would have it they were
discontinued and so I've been looking
for new products these are the ones I
found which work there's the Elizavecca
CER 100 collagen ceramide coating
protein treatment it does have protein
in it but the main star in this is
probably the amodimethicone the best
drugstore conditioner that I found which
has amodimethicone is this one
which I just found out has been
reformulated so the amodimethicone
is well down the ingredients list now I
told you I have the worst luck I've
probably cursed every
product in this video I'm so sorry make
sure you check the one you're buying the
Paul Mitchell strength super strong
liquid treatment is also full of
amodimethicone this one you use after you
finish washing your hair you step out of
the shower dry your hair off a bit and
then just spray this all over the bits
you want to treat comb it through and
then dry it and this binds our really
nicely into your hair the Daily Naturals
treatment detangler is also really good
the thing I like about this is that it
works really well on dry hair so on day
two or three if you realize you didn't
get quite enough detangling into your
hair you can just spray it on don't
touch it for a bit let it dry off and
then it goes really really silky and
again lots of amodimethicone another
brand that I've recently found is
Kerastase which has lots of products
that contain amodimethicone high in
the ingredients list I also use olaplex
on my hair olaplex number three is
the take home version I treat my hair
want about once a month with it it's
meant to repair sulfur sulfur bonds so if
you have broken sulfur sulfur bonds it
puts them back in place sort of I used
to use this a lot more but ever since I
discovered amodimethicone I found that
I don't actually need to some people say
that silicones cover up the damage but
to be honest that's what all
conditioners do they cover up the damage
nothing truly repairs damage the
important thing about conditioners is
that they do cover up the damage but
they also prevent further damage they
lubricate your hair so that when it
slides past it doesn't chip away at the
cuticle I found that without using
silicones I get so much more breakage
and split ends that it's not worth
avoiding them for me when I do do an
olaplex treatment I try to avoid using
amodimethicone for a couple of washes
beforehand so that it gets rid of most
of the film and the olaplex can
penetrate through but a lot of the time
I found that my hair just gets really
nasty and unmanageable and I get more
split ends during that phase so that's
probably why I use the olaplex a lot
less now because that is just too much
to sacrifice because I've been trying to
wash my hair a bit less but I am still
quite oily I found that dry shampoo is
really important
my favorite dry shampoo is probably the
batiste dry shampoo just because it is
strong enough to soak up my oil without
leaving my hair feeling
really gross and dirty one thing I found
though is that it tends to make my scalp
feel quite dry and irritated so I try to
keep it as far away from my head as
possible they have also recently
reformulated so hopefully it's a bit
less of a problem the other thing that I
found works really well is just
cornstarch in a shaker so this is just
a standard salt shaker I think pepper
shaker full of cornstarch I've been
using cornstarch on my face as well as a
setting powder and it works really well
for soaking up oil so with this I
usually use this on especially my fringe
which tends to get oily faster than the
rest of my hair at least it looks oily
and so I tend to just pop a bit on my
hand and then just slap it on rub it in
a bit and then comb it out and then
usually after a less than an hour it'll
start looking normal again it's not too
white something else that I discovered
is these clips I think they're called
crocodile clips maybe but these clips
are really really good if you have thick
coarse hair like mine that likes to just
run away they are really good for
holding a huge amount of hair so you can
see I can fit like that much worth of
hair which is pretty decent compared to
the skinny clips that you often find so
really really strong really good at
holding on lots of hair let's see how
much I can do
I can generally do about half my hair in
one of these which is pretty impressive
it's even more impressive when my hair
is wet and heavy yeah I used these back
when I was redyeing my hair I use these
in the shower I use these when I'm doing
an olaplex treatment as well I found
that different brands are different
qualities so this one for example is
from cricket it has lasted for a really
long time with lots of abuse like
dropping them in the shower all the time
holding up my heavy heavy hair some
other brands tend to crack a bit so this
one is one that's starting to crack
although it's still doing really well I
think it's also good if you check if the
squeezy bits are ridged or if they have
some sort of texture because when it's
wet or covered in conditioner it gets
really slippery so this one for example
is smooth which tends to get slippery
this one has a really dimpled texture
and that's really grippy even when it's
wet or covered in oil I did a
sponsored post ages ago about how Aquis
towels work that was before I had my
hair bleached after I've had my hair
bleached it's gotten even more useful
bleached hair is quite damaged and so
it tends to soak in water much more
easily and that means it's harder to get
the water out afterwards when you're
trying to dry your hair because of the
way that Aquis makes their microfiber
they have a really large surface area
which means they're really good at
soaking up water without you having to
work your hair around when your hair is
wet the cuticle scales tend to be a bit
raised which means that when your hair
strands mechanically bash into each
other you can cause lots and lots of
damage so having a towel like this means
that you can just squeeze your hair
without having to do that rubbing motion
and so you can reduce further damage
it's also really really light which
means that it's much better for if you
want to wrap your hair up and leave it
wrapped up which is what I do before I
dry my hair with a hair dryer my
favourite hair dryer that I've tried so far
is this one the Panasonic eh-na98 hair
dryer with the nanoe technology I've done
a video review of this before talking
about what I thought about it and the
science behind the product that was
sponsored this video is not sponsored
I'm just talking about it because I
genuinely really like it before I used
this I was using the Dyson supersonic
the main difference I found between the
two is that the Dyson supersonic tends
to dry out my hair especially the
bleached and damaged ends whereas this
one does not and so with this I get a
sort of crunchy straw like feel with
this one it is a lot less in terms of
weight they feel like they're around the
same weight the Dyson is actually a
hundred grams heavier but I feel like it
feels the same probably because the
weight is very centered around where
your hand is and so when you do this
there's not a lot of stabilizing you
have to do whereas with normal hair
dryers with the longer nozzle you do
have to do a bit more work in terms of
stabilizing in terms of loudness to me
they sound like they're around the same
the Dyson does have simpler heat
settings it's just got one two three
the panasonic has more complex settings
but i found that they actually fit my
hair drying routine better the three
that i use are the hot the cycling and
the scalp so the hot mode is just
standard hot
the cycling is when it alternates
between hot and cool which I found quite
useful when my hair is mostly dry but
still a bit wet if I use cold it would
just take forever so the cycling gives
me the benefits of having a cold setting
to set the style while still every once
in a while blasting it with heat to keep
the water evaporating the scalp mode is
amazing the scalp mode is just hot
enough to drive off water but it doesn't
quite hurt your scalp which is great
because that is probably the main
problem I have with most hair dryers the
medium is a little bit too hot for my
scalp and so once I switch it to scalp I
can just blast it at my roots and it's
fine so this hair dryer my hair feels
less dry it looks shinier I have had a
few questions about how this hair dryer
puts moisture into your hair without
changing your style or making it frizzy
I have a blog post on this it's again in
the description when I went to Europe
last April
Nadine Baggott introduced me to the
magic of tangle teezer detangling
brushes these brushes have a range of
different bristle lengths and they have
really smooth bristles and so when you
pull this through your hair it detangles
your hair without massive damage so
without a lot of pulling and you can
just sort of gently let it slide through
with a regular brush sometimes I can
hear the breakage happening which is
very freaky with this it is just very
low effort the hair detangles without a
lot of pulling or breakage which is
amazing the bristles are thin which
means they are a bit prone to getting
bent so you can see this one is starting
to get a bit manky looking so you are
meant to replace it but I found that it
does still work quite well probably should
replace it there so that is my lazy
colored hair care routine do you use any
of these products already? let me know
what you think in the comments you can
also let me know if you have any tips
for me that might also help as well if
you enjoyed this video I'd appreciate it
if you clicked the like if you subscribed
and if you clicked the notification bell
you can also follow me on Instagram for
lots of beauty tips and you can check
out my blog for lots of beauty science
articles see you next time